os quiero contar algunas cosas y por eso
que soy gente cercana me voy a atrever a
haceros una confesión
una confesión que seguramente muchos
considerarían un tanto dolorosa o
incluso un poco un poco deshonrosa pero
programa tengo miedo mira yo soy el
ingenuo
soy un completo ingenuo y toda mi vida
lo he sido
realmente hay formas más crudas de
decirlo en mi madre me lo dice cada día
darío eres un pardillo
soy un pardillo no lo aseguro hace
muchos años ya yo trabajaba en un centro
de menores para los que no lo sepáis un
centro de menores es realmente una
cárcel donde hay chicos jóvenes ahí
teníamos un poco de todo allí teníamos
allí teníamos gente que estaba imaginaos
por robo atraco desgraciadamente no sé
violaciones algún asesinato para mí
había días que era descorazonador
trabajar allí porque yo siempre he
tenido mucha empatía por la gente joven
siempre he visto una relación de ideas
juventud posibilidad potencial y desde
luego en aquel momento había muchos
chicos que parecían que ya habían
truncado su vida tan pronto
intentábamos hacer muchas cosas con
ellos y trabajar mucho con ellos en el
centro de menores se les daba clase cada
día se pretendía que sacaran el
bachillerato que por lo menos el
graduado escolar se le enseñaba a hacer
las cosas de casa imaginaos que menos
ordenar su habitación recogerla barrer
la limpiar su baño pero claro los chicos
nunca querían hacer esto esto para ellos
era una rutina muy pesada y como
escapaban de esto a través del pardillo
yo trabajaba allí de enfermero ellos
siempre pedían reunirse conmigo el rato
que estaban conmigo era un rato que
soltaban el lápiz que soltaban la escoba
era genial para ellos era un momento de
evasión se sentaban conmigo y me
contaban cada historia
allí teníamos absolutos mentirosos
embusteros manipuladores profesionales
os podéis imaginar algunos de ellos la
cantidad de careos que habían tenido ya
con un juez la cantidad de
interrogatorios que habían tenido con la
policía o con la guardia civil se la
sabían todas ya mí desde luego me la
daban con queso su pretensión era
siempre fingían simulaban no todos pero
algunos simulaban alguna dolencia alguna
lesión con la idea de ir al hospital ir
al hospital era un día de romper la
rutina era un día de campo perfecto
los fines de semana algunas veces
dependiendo de la medida de cada chico
el juez les daba
un fin de semana de permiso ellos se
iban el viernes con la idea de volver el
domingo por la tarde ellos tenían que
firmar un papel comprometiéndose a eso
de acuerdo nos llevaba ya mucho tiempo
allí llegue un lunes por la mañana y
había un barullo de gente estaban las
psicólogas el psiquiatra estaba
dirección maestros todos reunidos me
sorprendió a que yo digo bueno qué pasa
qué pasa aquí alguien me dijo darío el
jose el host y no ha vuelto no volvió
ayer domingo y mira hemos llamado a la
jueza y la jueza ha decretado busquen
capturar
mostra aquello me acuerdo que rebotó
mucho en mi cabeza no sé jose era un
chico de 16 años de los manipuladores os
lo aseguro y de lloverle tantas veces es
cierto que había creado no sea un
vínculo de amistad con él
lo que decimos en la mancha no el roce
hace el cariño y
y me dolió mucho aquello aparte busca y
captura yo creo que es muy influenciado
por el cine yo busca y captura- no se
llega a un helicóptero un comando baja
por unas cuerdas te ponen una capucha en
la cabeza te llevan acababa de entender
eso
no se me ocurrió nada más brillante que
decir
ostra pero lo habéis llamado no se ha
intentado hablar con él a lo mejor
simplemente el chico perdió en el
autobús
y la cara de mis compañeros de cómo me
miraban
algunos intentaba un poco disimular la
sonrisa otro se reía a carcajadas pero
sobre todo me miraba con esa idea
diciendo pero y este tío cuando se va a
caer del nido
y amiga maría que es una de las mejores
psicólogas infantiles que he conocido
nunca intentando ayudarme me dijo mira
daría o no no no te sepa mal estos que
se ríen de ti realmente todos tenemos
que ser un poco como tú tú nos tenemos
que ser crédulos para pensar que el
trabajo que hacemos aquí para con los
chicos lo hacemos bien
ostra maria que pienso que intentaba
ayudarme de verdad yo creo que vio más
en el pozo
pero es que no imagináis
como me persiguió esa con durante los
nueve años siguientes que trabajé allí
llegaba el lunes por la mañana y siempre
alguien había alguien que me decía y
darío a sesión y perdió el autobús
toda mi vida ha sido un partido así que
es cierto pero mira no lo interpretado
nunca en sentido negativo ser ingenuo
realmente como todos vosotros los
ingenuos tenemos ilusiones tenemos
sueños pero el peligro de los sin sueños
o sea el peligro de los ingenuos es que
nosotros no tenemos ningún complejo a
soñar porque un sueño pequeño porque una
meta pequeña una meta grande enorme
pero si eso es peligroso lo que lo que
es letal es que nos lo creemos nos lo
creemos no tenemos ninguna duda
uno de mis primeros sueños mis primeros
sueños grandes fue ir al rally parís
dakar o tenía ya unos 15 años era
navidad y yo estaba viendo en la tele un
reportaje que ponían de unos tipos que
iban en unas motos rarísimas en unos
coches parecían más demás más y
atravesaban desiertos ostras qué bonito
el tener
en el sáhara mauritania argelia senegal
marruecos estoy mi mente a volar ostras
me quedé prendado es de verdad todo lo
que caía por entonces no había en
internet pero todo lo que caía en mis
manos revistas prensa sobre sobre el
realidad que yo lo devoraba
además me di cuenta que aquella
filosofía de carrera iba mucho conmigo
allí lo importante no era ganar
o por lo menos no era para la mayoría sí
para cuatro quizás y para los medios
también era importante quién ganaba pero
allí la gente se apuntaba con la idea de
tener una experiencia con la idea de
tener una vivencia de vivir una aventura
de luchar contra el desierto solo con el
poder de su máquina con el poder de su
astucia con el poder de su de su ímpetu
no se habían generado un tipo de valores
que van también mucho conmigo con el
deporte la solidaridad el trabajo en
equipo el sobrevivir a una aventura así
el compañerismo la camaradería
de verdad estaba enamorado se esperaba
siempre que llegara navidad
no por los reyes que me traían nada sino
porque llegaba en la cara
y van pasando los años si aquello no se
me pasaba hice la carrera de enfermería
y yo seguía esperando navidad para ver
el dakar en la tele
tendría yo ya 25 años cuando salió un
reportaje sobre el equipo sanitario del
rally ostra ahí se me encendió una luz
ahí yo vi una puerta además yo nunca
tuve ya me podéis ver estoy un poco
fuera de forma ahora no pero nunca tuve
seguramente condiciones de piloto jamás
las tuve pero viendo aquello del equipo
sanitario vi cómo podía conjugar las dos
cosas que más me gustaban que era la
enfermería ayudar a los demás y el
rallye del cual me había enamorado así
es que
decidí ponerme a trabajar decidí empezar
un camino que me llevará hasta allí
y esto como lo hago bueno decidí que
tenía que acabar con un currículum o
tenía que acabar con algunas habilidades
con unos conocimientos que impidieran a
un director general de recursos humanos
allí en parís del rally que le
impidieran desechar mi currículum que no
pudiera hacerlo quería dejarles sin
argumentos
lo primero que empecé a hacer fue
estudiar francés que es el idioma del
dakar
y estaba yo en la escuela idioma de
ciudad real aprendiendo francés me
acuerdo que todos mis amigos me decían
incluso gente de mi familia pero pero
bueno pero qué haces ahora estudiando
francés y realmente francés ya no sirve
de nada la lengua de futuro si el inglés
y yo decía no es que estoy estudiando
francés porque quieren aplacar
claro me miraban así como una cara
este cuando se va a caer del nido
pero yo seguía yo a mí ya mi bola me
apunté a un montón de cursos de
orientación de navegación me encanta
esto de coordenadas porque si supierais
las coordenadas que tengo que manejar
cuando voy por esos desiertos osea no os
lo podéis imaginar
empecé a trabajar con mapas empecé
posteriormente con el tiempo a estudiar
inglés a estudiar italiano una vez me
apunté con mis amigos a sacarme el carné
de camión y ellos me decían pero vamos a
verdad yo si tú eres enfermero a ti no
te hace falta el carné de camión yo
hacia no si esto me va a sumar mucho
para ir al dakar
madre mía este tiempo se le pasa
tengo que reconocer que alguna vez ya va
siendo ya mayor esas miradas empezaban
mucho es verdad yo sé que lo hacían sin
mala intención
o sea que no querían herirme pero pero
era pesado siempre que te trataran así
de tal calidad ingenuo sí sí no no me
acababa de gustar de hecho yo me veía
que estaba siempre haciendo lo que hacía
en solitario luchando en solitario pero
es que ya me daba un poco de vergüenza
de decirlo lo hacía en voz baja
no me atrevía
pero yo seguía ya el año que menos
currículum mandé
a la organización del dakar serían 40
cada dirección de correo que cogía o
dirección física yo mandaba mi
currículum y aquí me contestaba
no ha pasado esto nunca
qué estás mandando cientos de currículum
que te crees la persona óptima para ese
trabajo que prácticamente en vez de
pedir estás ofreciendo y no te contesta
a nadie qué cruel es esto no debería
pasar
de hecho tanto tiempo sin recibir
respuesta quizás la que es un poco había
días que tenía como un ataque de
realidad y decía abajo a lo mejor no me
llaman nunca
que la leche empieza un camino tan largo
me he preparado tanto ya lo mejor no me
van a llamar nunca
pero como los ingenuos también somos muy
positivos que echaba la vida a la vista
atrás y veía todo lo que había hecho
y seamos sinceros muchas de las
habilidades muchas de las destrezas del
conocimiento que había obtenido me
estaban
provocando todavía sueños mayores que el
primero que de la carrera a que el del
rally pero no sólo eso yo me había
enriquecido había conocido nueva gente
nuevos círculos de amigos nuevas
filosofías incluso muchas ideas nuevas
había cambiado algunas de mis ideas
había cambiado algunos de mis
pensamientos había crecido bueno no sé
si era para conformarme pero me
encontraba encontraba feliz a pesar de
que no me llamaban pero sabéis qué
que me llamaron
me llamaron del dakar no os puedo
imaginar o sea era el año 2008 o algo
así y yo recibí un correo la directora
sanitaria del dakar me manda un correo
para decirme su candidatura es perfecta
pero todos los puestos están cubiertos
nos guardamos o currículum para futuras
ediciones a ver qué pasa y qué subidón
y al año siguiente un corta y pega del
primero
y así gente otra corta despliega pero ya
en el 2010 habla conmigo y me dice en el
dakar 2011 vienes con nosotros
increíble llevo 8 o sea gente a la que
yo había mirado toda mi vida mitos del
deporte a los que yo siempre miraba
desde abajo hoy de verdad son mis amigos
me llaman por teléfono me piden consejo
me piden colaboración
increíble
increíble de verdad había llegado a mi
sueño
qué cosas he aprendido de todo este
camino pues mirad he aprendido
he aprendido que la ingenuidad suma en
positivo la ingenuidad sólo puede sumar
impositivo a mí me pasó pero es que
ahora yo voy a preguntar acaso no
pensáis que aquel tipo francés que se
pasaba todo el día mirando por el
microscopio unos bichitos no tenían
mucha ingenuidad y mucha ilusión cuando
decidió llamar a su descubrimiento
vacunas
acaso pensáis que no tenía ni ilusión no
tenían sueños altos aquellos tipos que
en un garaje trabajando descubrieron un
aparato tan importante para la ciencia
para la medicina como se pueda llamar
hoy el tag o la resonancia nuclear
magnética pensáis que lo hicieron sin
ilusión
pensáis
que esos tipos año 1969 ninguno de los
que estábamos aquí habíamos nacido años
1969 que pensaban que querían llegar a
la luna y llegaron pensaban que no lo
hicieron con ilusión con ingenuidad
la ingenuidad suma en positivo no
tengáis duda de eso
y os voy a pedir un favor
estar siempre muy atentos porque lo más
valioso aquí es un ingenuo con talento y
el talento es universal el talento
existe en todos sitios
da igual si eres de manzanares da igual
si eres de saceruela de ciudad real da
igual si eres de barcelona si eres de
parís si eres de da igual el talento
está en todos sitios da igual si eres de
un país pobre da igual si eres de
marruecos además no entiende tampoco de
que es transversal no entiende de ricos
de pobres el talento existe en todos
sitios y son los ingenuos con talentos
los que tiran del carro los que tiran de
esta sociedad de la humanidad porque son
esos los que descubren las vacunas los
que inventan el tag y los que llegan a
la luna y esos nos empujan a nosotros lo
mejor alguno de los que estamos aquí yo
entre ellos nunca voy a hacer un
descubrimiento de eso es pero me
aprovecho del suyo me da mucha pena
cuando viajo por el mundo y veo chicos
que no va a explotar nunca su talento
porque tienen os acordáis lo que os
contaba de mí que yo sentía ese peso de
la mirada cuando cuando no me creían lo
que decía
eso era lo que yo siempre daba en llamar
un condicionamiento un condicionamiento
relativo chicos así van a tener siempre
un condicionamiento total absoluto en su
vida o imagináis y todos esos chicos que
tienen talento también pudieran trabajar
pudieran desarrollarse pudieran ir a la
universidad y estamos hablando de medio
mundo estoy seguro que hoy en nuestro
medio mecum estaría la cura del cáncer y
la cura del sida ya
pero estamos perdiendo tanto talento
me sucede también
por último ya
que si tuviera que sopesar qué fue lo
que más feliz me hizo qué fue lo que más
me llenó si ese camino tan duro que
empecé a llegar a la consecución de ese
fin
realmente no sabría qué decir pero mirar
el camino lo empecé yo lo decidí yo yo
era el dueño de mi camino yo decía que
quería hacer hacia dónde quería tirar
para dónde para dónde quería llevar mi
vida cuáles van a ser mis amigos todo
eso lo decidía yo
pero
el fin era incierto era dudoso no
dependía de mí el camino si dependía de
mí el fin no dependía de mí de todas
formas voy a decir una cosa el camino
puede llevar todavía a sueños mayores
que en el originario que el inicial por
eso ante la duda aunque el fin sea
dudoso aunque sea incierto
vosotros empezar siempre el camino
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]